Les verts s'enfoncent vraiment. Euh.
Parce qu'on les connaissait,
ils étaient 1 peu folkloriques, tu vois. Euh.
Mais là, ça, ça, ça dépasse l'entendement on dirait.
On a quasiment l'impression que c'est 1 secte
maintenant. Et donc c'est fabuleux.
Parce que je pense d'ailleurs
qu'ils vont se planter au niveau des élections
européennes pour la 1ère fois,
puisque les élections européennes,
ils ont toujours fait des très bons scores,
reconnaître
aux présidentielles, ils font des des scores minables,
et aux européennes,
ils ont toujours fait des des très bons scores.
Je pense que cette fois ça va changer
parce que là, c'est plus possible, les gens,
de se rendre compte que ce parti est devenu trop,
complètement fou quoi.
Là, j'ai vraiment l'impression que ça sentait 1 peu
la faim quoi.
Enfin je sais pas, c'est.
C'est vraiment très étrange
ces ces images qu'on a vues,
euh le le pro,
le sujet de l'environnement est repris par tous les
partis de façon très importante.
Donc les verres en plus, spécificité,
euh. En plus, la, les. Les verres, les. Comment dire.
La gauche mélenchonise,
disons. C'est devenu leur thème prioritaire quasiment.
Et donc euh. Moi je vois mal parti pour pour les verres
avec les leaders que.
Ils ont choisi en plus, hein.